yes so um just had a meeting with
minister cleverley um
lasted for a bit more than half an hour
um
if i'm honest quite a depressing meeting
um
you know he said listen i had a meeting
with the iranian deputy foreign minister
he's having a series of meetings with
other officials to go into the details
there'll be no more
discussion more progress that i can't go
into um
but in terms of what we got told
well not much
so you know he wanted to emphasize that
it had been a cordial meeting
uh and that you know um
you know that was a good step but but in
terms of
yeah he'd raised anthony's case at the
case of the others um
he said that was a good step and that
you know couldn't give a timeline on
when things were going to move forwards
so i think what richard wants most of
all from the foreign office is some
clarification about a number of things
but particularly the debt that britain
owes the iranians 400 million pounds
worth and counting with interest being
added to it for money that was paid by
the iranians in the 70s for tanks that
the british never delivered because the
iranian revolution happened after they
paid the money that's been a
bone of contention between the reigns
and the british ever since now an
international court of arbitration said
that came down on the side of the
iranian said that money should be paid
by the british it's been put into a
separate bank account it is there to be
paid to the iranians it's understood
that boris johnson the prime minister
believes it should be paid his defense
secretary ben wallace says it should be
paid liz trust a new foreign secretary
hasn't spoken about it yet but but
presumably
feels along the same lines as uh boris
johnson the iranians have made it pretty
clear to nazarene that until that
money's paid there's no chance of her
being released the british say the two
aren't linked but we've had uh jeremy
hunt former foreign secretary today
saying regardless of whether it's linked
or not it should be paid because
accorded said it should be paid and and
it's pretty clear there will be no
progress towards nazim be released until
that money is released and it's really
not clear as to why that money hasn't
been paid and i think richard's campaign
groups and lawyers are really hoping to
get more clarity from the government and
they didn't get it today i think what's
also causing concern is this seemed to
be seems to be being bound up now
with the preludes to the resumption of
iranian nuclear talks
nazanin's fate could be banned up with
that which is a much bigger issue and i
think gives even more cause for concern
even if that tank debt is settled
uh there could be no progress until
those talks are resumed and presumably
reached some kind of fruition so i think
a rather depressing evening awaits
richard ratcliff as he retires to his
tent somewhere behind me for a 20th
night i guess it will be and he's not
showing any signs yet of giving up his
hunger strike members his family said
they're pretty concerned about his
health but i think at least until the
iranian delegation has left glasgow at
cop26 he's pretty determined to stay
here whatever concerns there are about
his health